how are things with you you know I you
have such a lovely family my family's
hung out with your family a lovely wife
kids all going well I just took her to
Italy was great she loved it
good luck with that
yeah we're know my we have a lot of
animals yeah you do looting my sons
yeah we just know why I guess it's been
about a year we have well you have dogs
and we have rabbits and you have rabbits
I have a lot yeah we have that is that
relatively new I don't think I've seen
rats is 8 to 9 months old and I they we
got him and the boys loved him and then
we noticed one of them had was having
some scabs on its side I know and I was
like oh no it's awful so I took the poor
rabbit to the vet and the vet vet goes
yeah I've seen this before and if I'm
right and he turns it over
yeah the other rabbit ate its balls off
what yeah wait a minute
there's two rabbits in the cage two male
rats you'll be a rabbit yes and one male
rabbit ate the other ones testicles off
you are saying this like it's a
surprising thing yes that's what yes
it's terrifying why did the male rabbit
do that to the other were they was it an
accident were they engaging in some fun
and then what I wouldn't have you ever
heard of where someone accidentally bite
someone's balls off
I knew a guy in college Harvard so
famous ball biting festival around
homecoming yes so the apparently if you
have a couple met this can happen a
couple males get together and then one
of them establishes dominance and
doesn't want the other one
to procreate so he will remove the
testicles and then I said then but good
and I said well there's no other females
around and then the the yeah so what
would be the incentive it right female
and the vet was like you tell the rabbit
there isn't yeah yeah
they don't care yeah just in case just
in case any female ever shows up in
their tiny cage yeah he's this is a
proactive ball eating rabbit right he
prepares yeah so and I just imagine if
that one female happened to somehow get
in the cage the other one would be like
that guy bit my balls off yeah so then
we neutered but we neutered the other
one cuz the one was already
why didn't she let the other one neuter
the first one that should be fit yes I'm
getting a prize
they're cheering for a rabbit to
mutilate another rabbit in retaliation
yes Yuta Lee they're just cheering for
revenge yeah how it's just as a vowel
that understands the concept of revenge
in the rabbit kingdom
you